breastfeeding is a way to nourish your
baby with breast milk from your own body
milk is produced in mammary glands from
there it travels through milk ducts to
openings in your nipples when your baby
suckles on your nipples your body
releases the hormones prolactin and
oxytocin prolactin controls milk
production
and oxytocin controls the release or
letdown of milk through milk ducts
breastfeeding benefits your baby by
providing the optimal balance of
nutrients providing antibodies to
support your baby's immune system
reducing your baby's risk of asthma
allergies colic obesity diarrhea and
certain ear and lung infections
providing nutrients that are easily
digested and reducing your baby's risk
of sudden infant death syndrome
breastfeeding benefits you by giving you
a convenient inexpensive way to nourish
your baby helping you lose excess body
weight helping your uterus contract
after delivery and increasing the bond
between you and your baby there are four
basic breastfeeding positions cradle
hold position
side-lying position
cross cradle hold
and football hold
your baby is born with the instinct to
turn to your nipple with an open mouth
and suck to trigger this instinct
lightly stroke your baby's lips with
your nipple when your baby opens his or
her mouth position your nipple toward
the roof of the mouth and pull him or
her close to your breast it may take
some time for your baby to learn to get
his or her mouth around the nipple or
latch on when properly latched your
baby's mouth will cover your nipple and
most of your areola the darkened area
around your nipple your baby's lips will
curl out and his or her nose will touch
your breast
you should hear smooth regular sucking
sounds along with swallowing let your
baby nurse as long as he or she wants
many newborn baby's nurse 8 to 12 times
a day